bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint dans
filcho l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les grandes
lignes de cette émission l'enseigne
Bricorama à Montini le brotonux amené à
disparaître c'est ce que le directeur
régional de la marque a annoncé hier il
indique souffrir de l'interdiction
d'ouvrir le dimanche contrairement à ses
concurrents le ministère des Droits des
Femmes organise la première semaine de
l'égalité professionnelle à cette
occasion la CGPM organisé une conférence
à
véis et puis la la première industrie
culturelle en France n'est pas la
musique ni le cinéma mais les jeux
vidéos et nous verrons dans notre
dossier de la semaine que les ivblines
représentent un territoire majeur pour
ce secteur l'entretien de la semaine
sera quant à lui consacré au marché du
médicament de nombreux points fond débat
la vente en ligne par des pharmaciens la
vente à l'unité ou encore la
commercialisation dans les grandes
surfaces sur ce plateau nous invités
nous feront part de leur position nous
recevons Renaud Nji bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes donc le président du syndicat des
pharmaciens des ivelines et face à vous
nous retrouvons Mustapha Larbaoui
bonsoir qui est pharmacien à trappe on
vous retrouve dans un instant et on
passe pour l'instant à l'actualité
économique de la
semaine
on le disait dans les titres fermeture
annoncé de brecorama à Montini le
Bretonneux l'enseigne met en cause
l'interdiction du travail dominical un
reportage de yolen Torz et elodim
moine au mois de décembre ce magasin
Bricorama de Montini le Bretonneux sera
désormais fermé privé d'ouverture le
dimanche depuis près d'un an le magasin
a vu son chiffre d'affair diminué nous
constatons que nous n'avons pas de
report des ventes que nous avions le
dimanche sur le samedi notamment et que
les clients qui puisque ils ont la
possibilité l'opportunité d'aller chez
le roi Merlin ou Castorama qui eux
restent ouvert le dimanche et bien ne on
n pas de report de vente sur les autres
jours de la semaine une concurrence que
le magasin juge déloyal le roi Merlin et
Castorama à proximité ont en effet
obtenu une dérogation pour rester ouvert
le dimanche selon le président du groupe
Bricorama depuis la fermeture le
dimanche le magasin perdait 100000 € par
mois un magasin qui emploie 23 salariés
l'objectif de la direction est de zéro
licenciement les salariés notre volonté
c'est de les reclasser dans d'autres
magasins du groupe sur la région
parisienne Sylvie travaille depuis 23
ans dans ce magasin cette nouvelle LCI
attendait plus ou moins au départ on
devait rétrécir le le magasin donc après
surprise oui oui et non quoi parce que
euh quand on est ancienne depuis
l'ouverture du magasin donc c'est sûr
j'aurais préféré qu'il assiste le
magasin c'est sûr mais bon c'est comme
ça c'est les travaux coûtaient trop cher
le chiffre d'affaires n'était pas là
n'était pas au rendez-vous donc c'est
normal c'est très très dur mais bon on
va nous reclasser donc je pense que il y
aura pas de souci quoi j'ai un peu peur
de d'aller travailler par exemple à
Paris prendre les transports en commun
et tout c'est sûr mais j'aurais
peut-être pas le choix non plus on va
moi j'ai demandé au plus près parce
qu'on nous a déjà déjà demandé où on
voulait travailler donc j'ai demandé au
plus près le premier j'avais demandé
voisin après j'ai demandé enouiller et
après s'il y a pas bah ça sera ça sera
dans d'autres magasins on verra bien
d'autres en revanche semblent beaucoup
plus inquiets quant à leur avenir
Emmanuel lui n'a pour le moment reçu
aucune promesse de reclassement je suis
pas sûr de retrouver tout de suite du
boulot du jour au lendemain je risque de
ne plus avoir du
boulot la peur l'impact de la fermeture
dominicale pour pourrait ne pas
s'arrêter là deux autres magasins
également dans le rouge seraient eux
aussi menacés celui de voisin le
Bretonneux n'est pas concerné par une
fermeture le ministère des Droits des
Femmes organise la première semaine de
l'égalité professionnelle hommes et
femmes ne sont toujours pas égaux face à
à l'emploi les écarts de salaires
atteignent par exemple 27 % la
Confédération générale des petites et
moyennes entreprises la CGPME a réuni
avéisi des chefs d'entreprise pour faire
le bilan et parler du projet de loi qui
est actuellement en train d'être adopté
la présidente du groupe entrepreneuriat
au féminin souhaitait euh souhaiterait
pardon des améliorations on l'écoute on
est par exemple sur un congé parental
qui va devoir être pris en 50 50
aujourd'hui un couple entre guillemets
ne pourra plus choisir qui va prendre
son congé parental ça sera forcément 50
50 maintenant les deux n'ont pas
forcément toujours la possibilité de le
faire donc c'est de se battre sur ce
type d'élément et puis si quelqu'un veut
effectivement le faire qu' ait des
infrastructures à côté qui puissent
l'aider à savoir comment faire donc
aujourd'hui on est sur une vraie
bataille de fond de d'arrêter de dire on
met des quotas juste pour les cota ou
des pénalités juste pour des pénalités
et d'abord de chiffrer une cette
nouvelle loi en disant effectivement
proposer une nouvelle chos c'est très
bien mais si on sait pas queles sont les
moyens nécessaires et surtout qui va
payer il a un moment donné on sait que
comme les autres loises ne seront pas
appliqué hélas alors autre point noir de
cette loi selon la Confédération la
limitation des marchés publics aux
seules entreprises respectant les
dispositions en matière d'égalité pour
faciliter les démarches des petite
entreprise qui pourrait être plus
impacté la présidente de la CGPME a mis
en place une charte labélisée pour
valider entre guillemets leurs efforts
d'autres actions sont prévues je vous
propose de l'écouter on va créer aussi
un trophée féminin et on va avoir
justement avec le j'en parlais tout à
l'heure avec ce groupe de femmes des des
petites émissions télé où on va faire
passer des modèles les modèles
femmes du gaz 13 % moins cher c'est ce
que propose UFC Que Choisir en juillet
dernier l'association a lancé un appel
d'offre auprès de SEP fournisseurs de
gaz naturel le but de meilleures
conditions contractuell et le principe
de l'enchère inversé plus les clients
sont nombreux plus les prix sont bas
l'empiris a répondu à l'appel les
consommateur jusqu'au 25 novembre pour
s'inscrire sur le site
gazmoinscherensemble.fr et puis des bus
électriques yvelinois vont circuler à
Paris big green une filiale des auto des
autocars Dominique qui est basée à Buc a
remporté un appel d'offre auprès de la
Ville de Paris devan Sant la RTP ces bus
électriques circuleront dans le 15e
arrondissement nous avions suivi des
syndicalistes yvelinois le mois dernier
à Paris il manifestait contre la réforme
des retraites et notamment contre
l'allègement progressif de la durée de
cotisation 41 ans et demi à 43 ans mardi
une nouvelle manifestation a eu lieu
avant le vote à l'Assemblée nationale
mais le mouvement n'a pas fait flancher
le gouvernement la loi a été adoptée en
première lecture et puis pour finir nous
fêons aujourd'hui la 10e édition de M
tabî c'est un événement qui vise à
renforcer la bonne ambiance au travail
alors on a demandé à des des habitants
pardon des environs si eux aimaient leur
boîes je propose d'égûter leur réponse
très bien ça se passe très bien il y a
pas de problème bah oui j'aime bien ma
boîte on a une bonne ambiance et tout
donc oui c'est pas mal le patron est
sympa et tout on travaille bien en plus
en ce moment ça se passe bien se sentir
bien dans une boîte c'est pas évident
c'est pas toujours heureux c'est pas
facile oui moi je suis je me sens bien
dans mon travail oui je suis dans
l'informatique dans la joie et la bonne
humeur on espère non ça se passe bien
c'est une petite structure donc
justement je leur ramène les petit pain
en chocolat pour qu'il travaille mieux
et nous allons maintenant nous
intéresser au marché du médicament alors
le secteur évolue du côté du commerce
depuis le 12 juillet la vente en ligne
est autorisée un débat a né dernièrement
sur la possibilité pour les grandes
surfaces de commercialiser des
médicaments sans ordonnance pour le
gouverne pour le moment le gouvernement
s'y oppose pour baisser les coûts ou une
autre mesure encore est envisagée la
vente de médicaments à l'unité alors
pour parler de ces trois points nous
recevons sur notre plateau Mustapha
Larbaoui bonsoir vous êtes pharmacien à
trrappe et Renault Nji qui est président
du syndicat des pharmaciens dans les
ivelines vous avez tous les deux des
points de vues assez différents sur
l'évolution de votre métier on va le
voir alors commençons par la vente en
ligne depuis le 12 juillet des pharmaci
on peut ouvrir des sites et vendre
jusqu'à 4000 médicaments en vente libre
alors Renault NJ je pense que vous
souhaiteriez que cette vente soit
strictement réservée aux officines
pourquoi cela non je ne souhaite pas
c'est la loi aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
que il faut replacer le le propos c'est
une ordonnance une directive européenne
qui a autoriser euh compte tenu du
classement du médicament euh le la la
possibilité de la vente en ligne des des
médicaments la France a euh résisté euh
pendant de nombreuses années et au 1er J
janvier de cette année et bien on a
ouvert voilà la possibilité de pouvoir
vendre des enfin distribuer vendre
vendre vendre des médicaments c'est pas
dispenser c'est vendre des médicaments
en ligne euh sans ordonnance on rappelle
alors dans un premier temps c'était tous
les médicaments qui étaient en libre
accès c'est-à-dire qui aujourd'hui sont
déjà la portée des de la patientelle à
l'intérieur même des officines avec un
avec une une concurrence évidente sur
les prix donc et que par
l'intervention de certaines personnes il
y a eu un amendement et aujourd'hui le
juge a décidé que c'était ouvert à tous
les
médicaments à prescription facultative
ça veut dire qu'on ouvre trop largement
le champ du médicament le problème c'est
le manque de contrôle finalement face au
le problème c'est que le médicament est
un produit actif on comm commence à
s'apercevoir que le médicament peut tuer
s'il est mal utilisé et ben nous
pharmaciens nous avons passé un doctorat
d'État pour savoir ça et pour non pas
pour donner la leçon à qui que ce soit
mais juste pour accompagner la santé
publique et essayer de travailler au
mieux dans l'intérêt de la patientelle
en fonction de pathologie alors avant de
vous faire réagir Mustapha laboui je
vous propose d'écouter donc la seule
pharmacienne qui pour l'instant donc
autorisé à vendre des médicaments en
ligne dans les ivelines elle reçoit
jusqu'à 30000 visites par mois on
l'écoute je pense que la vente en ligne
de médicament sera le quotidien
collectif dans dans 20 ans comme ça est
aujourd'hui pour la vente en ligne de
livres en plus c'est un assouplissement
des règles de l'Europe et donc l'Europe
est incontournable et nous sommes
obligés de nous adapter et je pense que
il faut que ce soi les pharmaciens qui
aient les sites internet ça évitera
justement toutes les contrefaçons et
et ça sécurise au niveau des des
patients c'est très strict mais il le
faut alors là je suis complètement
d'accord là-dessus on ne doit pas
vendent déjà de médicaments qui sont sur
prescription médicale et c'est ce sont
des médicaments de vente beaucoup plus
courantes que nous pouvons mettre et je
trouve que c'est c'est une bonne chose
parce que ça évite justement toutes les
erreurs de dosage tous
les je fais d'ailleurs très attention à
ça moi dans une commande je regarde
toujours s'il y a deux médic qui ne sont
pas compatibles entre eux ou j'appelle
le client ou bien on communique par mail
pour certains mais pour savoir quelle
est la raison alors donc Madame
Chevalier a déposé son nom de domaine en
1997 comme quoi elle avait une vision à
long terme Mustapha labaoui est-ce que
vous avez un peu le le même avis il faut
avancer c'est dans l'ordre des choses
tout en sécurisant et en laissant
finalement la vente en ligne au
pharmaciens seulement alors pour le coup
je reviens pas sur les propos de
monsieur Nji puisque là-dessus on sera
d'accord c'est-à-dire que il y a des il
y a des règles il y a des lois elles ont
été rappelées c'est vrai que de toute
façon il y a il y a un juge de paix
au-delà de de l'ordre de l'ordre ou du
syndicat le juge de paix ça reste le
consommateur le destructeur de valeur
finale c'est le consommateur et là il
s'agit pas d'opposer encore une fois
l'économie on est sur une une émission
de d'économie donc il est vrai que
l'économie prime de plus en plus il
s'agit pas d'opposer les deux ce que dit
Monsieur NJ sur le sur les principes les
grands principes de droit et il y a une
digue sur lequelle on pourra pas revenir
c'est bien évidemment la notion de
sécurité la notion de sécurité vous
l'avez à l'officine par le circuit de
distribution de médicaments cette
fois-ci on parle plus de vente mais on
parle de délivrance et les mots ont un
sens dans notre profession la
traçabilité des Médicam voilà tous les
repères finalement sont là pour la
fiabilité de la délivrance du médicament
là il s'agit de de parfaire un circuit
de distribution qui serait celui
finalement de rentrer dans nouvelle
meurs notre façon
d'acheter à partir du moment où on est
effectivement dans ce type de de
démarche c'est-à-dire c'est un site qui
repose sur une officine qui est
identifiée sur lequel le principe de
sécurité et du
médicament vendus cette fois-ci avec
toutes les
sécurités possi pour moi ne me pose pour
le coup aucun problème d'autant plus que
je suis pour plutôt pour
l'expérimentation on parler tout à
l'heure des des ventes de médicaments à
l'unité
mais avancer je un peu pris par le temps
justement sur V à l'unité un mot sur un
mot sur le le le site internet il y a au
moins un avantage c'est que si de plus
en plus de gens mettent leur médicaments
on répète de médicaments non
remboursables encore une fois sans
prescription il y a un avantage c'est
cette c'est la c'est la comparaison au
moins sur les prix parce que existe
également ça
nous prochain débat sur la concurrence
qui s'ouvre également hors circuit
officinal alors justement donc sur vous
l'avanciez sur cette vente à l'unité
donc pour l'instant c'est c'est encore à
l'étude est-ce que déjà économiquement
est-ce que ce serait rentable parce que
c'est un peu ça le but finalement
écoutez économiquement tout peut être
rentable ça dépend où est-ce qu'on met
le curseur la vente en ligne la vente à
l'unité du médicament à un moment il va
falloir quand même rémunérer le
pharmacien son équipe sur ce
travail complémentaire supplémentaire
alors ça c'est le côté économique mais
encore une fois est-ce que c'est le seul
sujet on a fait des avancées
extraordinaires sur la
sécurisation du médicament il y a dans
les codes bar le numéro de l'eau la date
de péremption la possibilité de rappeler
des lots on l'a régulièrement
rappelez-vous l'histoire du lasilx de
ta on a mis des pictogrammes en fonction
des interactions éventuelles ou des
précautions à prendre moi je pense aux
personnes âgées la France est un pays
qui vieillit alors il va falloir des
loupes de plus en plus importante pour
qu'on arrive à voir le nom il y a la la
problématique des notices d'emploi qui
sont une obligation pour le cou européen
donc traçabilité qui devient vraiment
compliqué il nous reste une minute
peut-être pour répondre à à cela je
crois que vous avez testé vous la la
vente à l'unité alors moi jeai testé
mais pour le coup je l'ai testé à titre
personnel puisque c'était lors d'un
voyage au Canada il y a très longtemps
de cela je l'ai testé effectivement j'ai
eu une prescription de médicament à
l'unité je suis allé chez mon pharmacien
à l'époque dans une ville québécoise et
on m'a remis des médicaments à l'unité
j'ai eu ma prescription cela étant ce
n'était qu'un ce n'était qu'un thème ce
n'est qu'un témoignage de d'un passant
celui du professionnel rejoint très
nettement ce que vient de dire notre ami
euh monsieur NJ c'est vrai que je suis
pour la je suis pour la
l'expérimentation mais on va voir que ça
va ouvrir des champs absolument
monstrueux de en terme de développement
et de sécurisation il me semble aussi
que le premier sujet c'est quoi pourquoi
est-ce qu'on le fait pour faire des
économies en terme de de de de
récupération de produits et bien le
premier sujet c'est permettre au
pharmaciens d'accompagner la bonne
utilisation du médicament donc la
sécurité avant tout observance
c'est-à-dire que quand on pour 5 jours
et ben il faut les prendre pour 5 jours
et pas pour de parce que les TR jours on
les met à
la et de la même manière que aujourd'hui
un médicament sort avec une autorisation
de mise surmché une dose et une durée de
traitement et ben faut respecter ça très
bien je vous remercie en tout cas tous
les deux tu un peu pris par le temps
mais merci d'être venu sur notre plateau
pour débattre à ce sujet et on passe
maintenant auudessus de la
Merci
le dossier de la semaine est consacré au
marché du jeu vidéo en 2011 les volumes
de vente atteignent 2,7 milliards
d'euros en France et les Yveline
représente un territoire clé du secteur
des jeux vidéos nous sommes allés à la
rencontre d'une entreprise et d'un
centre de formation yvelinois des images
de Michel Jarry et Jonathan
villman première industrie culturelle en
France en terme de chiffre d'affaires le
marché devant celui du cinéma et de la
musique et les ivelines en étant des
territoires clés selon une étude du
Centre rional d'observation du commerce
de l'industrie et des services le
crossis 81 % des effectifs sont situés
en Île-de-France et près de la moitié
d'entre eux dans notre département
l'éditeur de World of Warcraft Blizzard
a par exemple décidé d'installer ses
locaux à versaill l'année dernière la
ville avait accueilli des fans de tout
le pays pour le lancement mondial du jeu
vidéo Starcraft 2 Vincent dononden
travaille dans le jeu vidéo depuis 14
ans jusqu'en 2008 il travaillait pour
viv Indy Games mobile à véis mais
l'entreprise a fusionné à l'époque avec
Activision sans emploi il décide de
fonder avec d'ancien collègues sa propre
société bulkyipix au démarrage on était
vraiment parti pour créer un studio de
développement et très vite ce qui s'est
passé sur l'App Store c'est qu'on a eu
un succès qui était histia project et
immédiatement derrière maille brut de
fil en aiguille moi je me suis dit
pendant 7 ans avant j'avais fait de
l'édition pourquoi pas reproduire c'est
le bon moment il y a une fenêtre cette
fenêtre il faut s'engouffrer maintenant
puisqueaprès quand c'est plus l'heure
c'est plus l'heure donc on y a été et
finalement petit à petit on est venu de
seulement producteur de contenu à
éditeur et pour des tiers et maintenant
on travaille avec on va dire environ une
centaine de de développeurs dans le
monde car il y a 5 ans le marché des
jeux vidéos physiques décline au profit
des jeux pour smartphone ou tablette
bullkipic s'est positionnée à temps elle
enregistre chaque année de 100 à 200 %
de croissance et espère atteindre en
2003 1 5 millions de chiffres d'affaires
dans ces bureaux on crée de nouveaux
jeux tout part d'un concept des game
designers préparent un document de base
avec règles du jeu personnage et niveau
des graphistes conçoivent alors
l'univers et les décors et les
programmeurs de leur côté se chargent de
la partie technique les algorithmes une
fois qu'on a identifié le jeu et qu'on
sait où on veut aller on fait les
estimations chacun dans les corps de
métier et ensuite on part en production
donc les graphistes eux ont une bonne
vision de de l'univers du jeu et vont
bah du coup faire les dessins faire les
animations modéliser les personnages le
game designer lui va faire ses réglag
faire ses niveaux et les programmeurs
ben nous on est un peu en bout de chaîne
puisqu'on va intégrer à la fois les
réglages du game design les niveaux du
game design et les ressources graphiques
fait par les graphistes pour assembler
tout ça et arriver à faire un jeu ou une
application dernier jeu développer
Astérix megabff bulkyix réalise
également des jeux en coédition voire
pour le le compte d'autres entreprises
autre activité de la société l'édition
de jeux vidéo elle indique recevoir de
15 à 20 jeux par jour leur plusvalue les
rendre visibles la réalité c'est que
quand un jeu sort sur sur l'App Store ou
sur les les smartphones et tablettes il
y en a un sur 10 qui va qui va réussir
ne serait-ce qu'à se rentabiliser donc
ça veut dire que il y a énormément de de
de petites sociétés qui vont aller au
cas PIP et qui vont avoir investi leur
argent pas parce que le jeu n'est pas
bon mais parce qu'ils auront pas la
visibilité suffisante à apporter au jeux
donc nous c'est c'est la valeur ajoutée
de de Bul pic c'est de repérer les jeux
de qualité et d'être capable de leur
donner une visibilité auprès d'Apple
auprès de Google et des différentes
plateformes digitales pour se faire
bulkyipix compte sur une bonne étude de
marché et une bonne communication grâce
à son carnet de 11000 journalistes son
réseau de professionnels du marché mais
aussi ses relations avec Google et Apple
une équipe chargée du marketing et du
business développement et d'ailleurs
située à San Francisco mais surtout il
faut choisir le bon jeu comme on a les
médior du disque à côté de ça il y a les
labels indépendants nous on est le label
indépendant sur les smartphones et
tablettes et dans le digital en général
donc on essaie de trouver des jeux qui
ont une patte quelque chose de vraiment
différent et comme par exemple un jeu
que que l'on a sorti la semaine dernière
qui s'appelle type rider et qui est
numéro 1 sur l'App Store iPhone et iPad
voilà donc c'est un jeu sur la
typographie c'est le genre d'expérience
qu'on essaie de trouver typ Rider toute
cette semaine numéro 1 des applications
payantes sur l'Apple Store si les
Français sont attirés par les jeux
vidéos le sont-ils également par les
métiers de ce secteur en Île-de-France
on dénombre une trentaine de formations
à traape l'école 3IS a ouvert en 2011
une formation spécifique elle propose de
former des étudiants aux arts numériques
puis de se spécialiser en jeux vidéo ou
en cinéma d'animation la première
promotion sortira cette année mais sur
les 30 élèves seul 10 ont choisi la
spécialité jeux vidéo a PR ils sont pas
ils n'arrivent pas en disant mon rêve
c'est le jeu vidéo pas forcément ils
sont très très intéressés par le cinéma
par le cinéma 3D par les productions de
dreamwork de Walt Disney des Américains
aussi ce qui se fait en France moi moche
et méchant des choses comme ça et puis
pour beaucoup d'entre eux en fait c'est
une découverte parce qu'il joue il joue
beaucoup mais de jouer à passer derrière
il il y a tout un monde et ça prend un
petit peu de temps pour pour se rendre
compte de ce que c'est vraiment que le
jeu vidéo quoi William fait partie de
ces élèves qui jouent mais qui aiment
également les dessous des jeux vidéos on
va dire que vidéo ça permet une
interaction ça permet de raconter une
histoire mais également de faire
interagir spectateur ça lui permet de
découvrir l'univers avec ses propres
yeux mais on va également pouvoir le
guider on va pouvoir lui mettre des
énigmes on va pouvoir le piéger donc
c'est une partie très intéressante je
trouve dans jeu vidéo qu'on a pas le C
d'animation durant ces tro années
William a appris les bases académiques
le dessin classique la perspective la
lumière la scénographie puis les bases
de la 2D de la 3D comme sur ces
logiciels cette tête on l'a modélisé une
fois on l'a dupliqué avec différentes
expressions de visage toujours avec le
même nombre de points et à chaque fois
on a demandé à cette tête sur la
contrainte par exemple circonspect
d'avoir l'expression qui a été modélisée
et donc du coup il permet d'avoir un
morphe d'une modification entre les deux
avec toutes les transitions ce qui
permet comme ça d'animer plus simplement
on pareil pour
triste voilà et ainsi de suite ce
passionné de jeux vidéo ne se fait pas
de souci pour son avenir il est persuadé
qu'il y aura de la place pour les jeunes
pourtant en France on ne compte que 5000
personnes dans ce secteur mais les
choses pourraient évoluer c'est si on se
limite vraiment au secteur du
vidéoludique c'est-à-dire du
divertissement mais le jeu couvre des
des secteurs beaucoup plus vastes que ça
le jeu couvre des secteurs en entreprise
dans toutes les secteurs de l'industrie
sur le serius game le jeu est en train
de pénétrer dans les musées aujourd'hui
on fait plus une exposition on fait un
parcours d'exposition c'est-à-dire qu'on
fait appel à quelque chose qui est du
domaine de de de du jeu hein de tourner
à gauche tourner à droite que va-t-il se
passer donc je crois que dans les
débouchés il faut pas pas se contenter
de penser aux grosses sociétés ou au
jeux mobiles il faut voir que c'est une
un mode d'interaction qui devient
indispensable dans nos sociétés quel que
soit le secteur dans lequel vous évoluez
bulkyix produit déjà jeux et
applications pour des marques ou des
agences de communication l'autre
diversification de ce marché repose sur
les nouveaux supports PS4 Xbox one et
bien d'autres encore tout le monde
disait le PC mort alors que la
plateforme Steam est en train d'exploser
et ils ont annoncé ce qu'ils appellent
les steam machines qui qui sont des ni
plus ni moins que des gros PC de salon
qui vont être disponibl l'année
prochaine et après il y a des choses un
petit peu plus spécial qui qui arrivve
comme des lunettes de réalité virtuelle
l'oculus rift qui qui vont annoncer des
grosses révolutions dans le jeu vidéo et
c'est pareil on est déjà très clairement
en train de regarder ce qu'on peut faire
donc je dirais que on est au début d'un
nouveau cycle économique et c'est un
petit peu ça le le jeu vidéo là on était
un peu dans dans la grosse crise et fin
de cycle et là on a toutes les des
portes qui sont ouvertes devant nous de
petites révolutions qui ouvrent bien des
perspectives le gouvernement souhaite
d'ailleurs soutenir ce secteur Fleur
Pellerin ministre délégué à l'économie
numérique multiplie les annonces
création de quartiers numériques
partenariat avec Ubisoft dont une aide
financière de 3,5 millions pour l'État
et création d'un groupe de travail au
Sénat ce dernier préconise notamment de
renforcer l'offre de capital risque à
ses
entreprises et c'est la fin de ce filcho
merci d'avoir été avec nous je vous
donne rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour un prochain numéro bonne
soirée